but first thing tonight we begin i have
a message for chuckie schumer
now recently he tells an online
publication quote
donald trump controls republican
primaries he controls the media
he tells fox news host sean hannity to
say something and he will
okay first of all chucky i hate to burst
your bubble
you know you live in that new york woke
cancel culture bubble of yours
socialistic utopia it's not true
this show has and always will be
independent nobody tells me what to say
to say instead on this show unlike
the networks you usually watch we follow
the truth
we were right on russia they weren't
we're right on a lot of stories they're
wrong on
without a doubt trump's america first
agenda it worked
and it worked big time lower taxes fewer
regulations
choice in school free market solution to
health care energy independence
peace through strength secure borders
you name it oh yeah and a core belief
that our freedoms are not given to us
from government
but they're natural rights from god
above our creator
joe didn't remember and doubted by the
thing you know the thing
the thing the thing our u.s constitution
by the way chucky i've supported this
agenda for 33 years on radio
25 at fox now chucky if you weren't so
delusional from your decades in the
sewer the swamp of dc
you might realize this program is one of
the only
outlets highlighting these core american
principles
nearly every other network every
newspaper every broadcast network
every website takes their marching
orders from your
liberal democratic socialist new green
deal party
like one huge giant liberal leftist
socialist echo chamber you all repeat
the exact same talking points
over and over and over again we've got
the proof take a look
this idea propagated by the president
and others that it is a fake dossier
that's just not true steele dossier
dossier of
alleged dirt dossier impeachment
impeachable impeached impeachment
impeachment impeachment impeachment
impeachment impeachable teachable the
presidency is effectively a russian op
right a dizzying 24 hours in the russia
investigation
rushing russia the russian russians
rushing russia
russia russia russia russia russia
russia russians through stormy daniels
stormy daniels the stormy saga
the stormy daniels um affair adult film
star stormy daniels
he's a polar is there a difference if
the president said
uh whole house do you think these
countries are
holes donald trump has turned the oval
office into a
hope the media mob democratic party big
tech they have
zero fidelity to something called the
truth from the russia hoax to justice
kavanaugh
the dirty russian disinformation dossier
last summer's violent riots that they
wouldn't call riots
you know their narrative is always more
important to the left than actually
telling the american people the truth
well case in point you can turn on fake
news cnn
i don't know why you would or ms dnc
you're likely not going to hear anything
about the negative
about joe biden's horrendous presidency
the fact that he's weak
and frail and struggling cognitively
they don't show you those tapes
we now have inflation going through the
roof every american is paying more for
everything
our dollar is losing value every day
new home construction saw a massive
huge frankly a frightening drop because
of the price of lumber and everything
else needed to build the home it's now
at a record high
manufacturing costs they're also rising
at a record pace
all americans are paying more we see
what's happening with gas
prices also surging will cost more to
fill up your tank heat and cool your
home
you still see ongoing shortages of
gasoline on the east coast
and now 19 states they're pleading with
joe biden
to please reinstate the keystone xl
pipeline
which would significantly increase the
supply of oil and gas into the u.s
something by the way that john kerry and
jennifer graham home said
oh that's the best way to transport oil
well doesn't seem like common sense
exists anywhere at this point
we have russian hackers that just
successfully disrupted
the supply of the lifeblood of the
world's economy oil and gas to the east
coast of this country for weeks
joe biden doesn't seem to understand and
get this
in fact he's now waving u.s sanctions
on a russian pipeline into europe
wow this is what america last policies
look like
maybe the equivalent of let's make
russia and let's make putin rich again
putin must be laughing all the way to
the bank could you imagine if this was
donald trump
the mob the media they would be
exploding their heads would explode
right now
the coverage they'd be apoplectic but of
course biden
well he's never going to receive the
same treatment look at what happened
today
during his visit to michigan one of the
rare trips out of the white house
i'm sure he's very tired he took an
electric truck for a test drive
and then threatened a run over a
reporter for asking too many questions
how dare you ask a question i need
permission to answer questions
take a look mr president how fast were
you going
okay i'm just gonna step on it i'll come
off at 80 miles an hour you'll see what
it is okay
you ready mr president can we ask you a
quick question on israel before you
drive
no you can't not unless you get in front
of the car as i step on it
okay here we go imagine the feigned
moral outrage
from the media if it was donald trump
joe biden he always gets a pass
first it was the candidate protection
program now it's the presidential
protection program gets a pass on
everything especially
the obvious his ongoing well cognitive
struggles and weakness
every week we see more and more evidence
that joe biden
frail weak irritable frequently confused
and every week the media simply ignores
it here are just a few examples from
just the past two days take a look a
machine
to leave where's rasheed i tell you what
rasheed
i want to say to you that uh i admire
your
intellect you know
i think some people think i'm too uh
proud of what the united states always
did
our own department of energy pioneered
and transformed the battery injury when
barack and i were in office
this is all the astromedical vaccine
produced in the united states all of it
four months ago was audacious goal that
we had
to put a million shots in the arms in my
first hundred days as president
100 million i should say
joe
oh her name is rashida
not rasheed did you lose your spot again
scary anyway the anti-semitic
anti-israeli congresswoman from michigan
met joe on the tarmac today and he still
couldn't quite get her name right
either way joe refuses to condemn to
leave's vicious
virulent anti-israeli remarks like when
she accused israel of terrorism
and called for netanyahu to be
prosecuted for war crimes in fact
joe biden refuses to call out any
members of the squad
despite some very vicious atrocious
statements about our greatest ally
israel in the middle east why
seems that joe seems like chucky and
nancy are all afraid of the squad
we'll have more on the radical socialist
base that runs the democratic socialist
party in a minute
first we turn to breaking news
surrounding zero experience hunter joe
biden
and family the syndicate now according
to a brand new report luke rosiak in the
daily wire in 2014
zero experience hunter was busy looking
for ways
to cut his dad the vice president into
the sketchy
foreign business deals that he was doing
for the syndicate
now one newly unearthed email hunter
references quote
2016 when jrb1 comes on board
jrb that would be joe's name joseph
robinette biden
and in 2016 joe biden was still the vice
president of the us
and remember hunter's business deals
were incredibly unusual
no experience in finance no experience
in oil
or gas or anything to do with energy or
any major industry
sketchy foreign nationals from russia
china ukraine
kazakhstan forking over millions of
dollars for what
look at this map put together by the
daily wire based on analysis from them
now these are all the countries some of
which we hadn't heard before
where hunter biden either discussed or
executed deals
you're looking at pretty much a who's
who of corrupt countries
china russia kazakhstan ukraine romania
qatar
the uae the ivory coast zimbabwe along
with various latin american countries
so why on earth was zero experienced
hunter
doing business with any of these
countries and why were they so happy to
fork over the cash to a crack addict
with no relevant experience now the
answer is obvious they were paying for
access to daddy and now the question
remains did joe biden get a cut
now this is a serious question imagine
if the name was trump
but the body that's supposed to perform
oversight of the executive branch is now
busy
rehashing the events of january 6. now i
will
openly admit on this program i was one
of the first people to call
for a commission we can't have what
happened on january 6
ever happen again it's like we can't
have rioting and
city blocks taken over like happened
last summer well
i said maybe we need this something
similar to a 911 commission
but after watching the democrats day
after day hour after hour
it's obvious they cannot be entrusted in
any way
shape manner or form to conduct any fear
fair hearing whatsoever they're
incapable of it
they're consumed with hatred of donald
trump 24
7. so any proceeding would be used as
yet another smear campaign against
donald trump all republicans and trump
supporters everywhere
it's not worth the time of day hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else